you might not want to eat the groceries
you see inside a new Los Angeles
supermarket that's because the products
are made of felt it's the brainchild of
British artist Lucy Sparrow who
transformed 2,800 square feet of the
standard hotel in two aisles stocked
with hand-sewn groceries you can buy
anything in the store Jamie yuccas
explains how Sparrow is really selling
the familiar comforts of home customers
crowd the aisles of Sparrow mark where
everything from Pizza of peanut butter
is hand made from felt felt is a very
childlike fabric and it often evokes
nostalgia okay so I think it often harks
back to being at school and some of your
first craft projects I just take it to
the extreme there's sushi and soda
artist Lucy Sparrow spent a year sewing
and painting the 31 thousand items that
line store shelves but this art exhibit
is hands-on and every piece is up for
grabs
the fact that it provokes happiness and
a sense of excitement that you wouldn't
necessarily have in other art shows and
it's also so inclusive it welcomes
people in that wouldn't necessarily go
to galleries Sparrow is clearly obsessed
with felt she lives and works on a farm
outside of London and calls her office
the felt cave four years ago I was still
working as a receptionist in central
London I did a Kickstarter campaign to
fund my first big show her first show a
corner shop in London's East End created
a frenzy on Instagram and the art world
took notice 200 pounds you can get Lucky
Charms and milk in 2017 Sparrow built a
bodega in the Big Apple 9,000 pieces
sold out the LA pop up also includes a
gallery this customer has her eye on the
Campbell Soup creation with a price tag
of $10,000
I think the imagery reminds me of
the Warhol the pop art of the 60s
something I identify with and my
childhood sparrows creations evoke warm
and fuzzy feelings her felt Fantasyland
is a celebration of brands connecting
people with life experiences I've just
got a dream it's just a little more
unusual than everyone else's I just want
to make real life out felt for CBS this
morning
Jamie yuccas Los Angeles is a very cool
girl they're very cool but that is a lot
of hands so a lot of carpal tunnel it's
small stitching